okay for those who are joining our
livestream this is another episode in
our design of this symbolic neuron that
framework for the next version often
language just a second here um and we
are looking I think at dealing with
persistent state in neural nets and I
think we had a design for doing this
last time let's take a look at this can
I just run this it should work but I
can't guarantee it on your build
okay something happened okay so net
state object is the way of taking a net
and also representing some state
information about the net in addition to
the actual net is that correct yes
specifically the recurrent states I
think this recycling icon is bizarre but
anyway let's for a second
okay so then then what you're doing here
is a nest so what is this so this is
this is some kind of okay all right so
this is going to then predict what to do
next from this hello that correct yes
and it's gonna believe some different
thing it's gonna magnificently predict
what what hello should be followed by
it's not a very convincing prediction
having trained it on anything bits right
um and and how does the training relate
to this state object business you don't
you don't train it on on the state
object you just train it on the direct
net they're different methods of doing
that so you can give it can we try
something more real can we try this for
a for something um yeah what could we
try it for I mean we could do something
like Alice in Wonderland and no no I
don't mean I mean something which has
been pre trained so that we actually
have a hope of being able to have
something reasonable happen oh we don't
have any pre tree into the language
models yet unfortunately we don't have
so Tim is busy working on a language
model they'll be one soon okay all right
fair enough okay
so do we have documentation for this net
state object then no we should we should
create that when we hadn't got that far
last time we had to move on to the
machine learning meeting so we didn't
have time to make a stage for that okay
all right um let me see whether I can
actually do that in this build
start talking tools and so on so this
works
okay so we don't have a net state object
page we just test yeah did we ever put
the wrapper what are we doing with the
net evaluation function business we
decided that we were going to use the
function repository for that so for now
we just gonna have a pure function in
the in the model the model galleries a
and nothing but repository yeah so did
we document that in net model that there
is such a thing
we have nuts okay so in here possible
properties in net model include
presumably should include this right yes
what's this implementers what is it
called I think what it's calling it
evaluation function okay as opposed to
evaluation net exactly are you sure
that's the right thing because it's the
meaning of evaluation is brought well I
know no yeah you're right you're right
you're right you're right but that is
the right thing to call it okay well
let's add a line here for a valuation
function is that is that coming in in
the next few days I think so but it can
also be added yes so it just has to be
additive result repository that's the
only thing and that's asynchronously
updated from normal reading but we
should have it here so okay so what is
this function what what's the what what
is the correct description a just tell
me what it is it's it's you is there a
preprocessor and a post processor as
this thing wrapped around the whole
thing
so it takes the network and it can do
arbitrary operations on the input and
the network it could have value at the
next evaluation function is f what does
it what is actually computed so it
computes F of then I guess then the net
is often in the pure function so it
takes on the input as the main input so
f all right
okay okay so then this is so then the
the function the network is referred to
by its net model designation inside the
evaluation function but that doesn't
work because that's a that's just that's
self referential that's not the
valuation it will be referred to inside
the valuation function oh I see I see
okay okay all right
complete function to be used for
evaluation right so we should say when
applied
when one
present
evaluation function defines the complete
specifies the complete evaluation
I suppose there that's
exactly what we said right here
how should we say this were the way to
say it is that this Trump's evaluation
net right present evaluation function
it calls evaluation function you know
what what why don't we do this why don't
we say the default
the default the effective default value
for evaluation function is net mod I
start evaluation net correct right I
agree okay great
that's that okay now let's go on to net
state object and there are no other
functions that there are no other new
functions we have to bring in here I've
on two minds about this I think there's
a case for I think I mentioned this last
time there's a case for function calls
or something like knit attach loss well
when you do training you don't have to
specify the loss that a loss function or
how you're going to turn the net that
your training into a training Network
because normally you'd like add on these
like auxilary pieces that that match
that the output of the net with desired
output using that loss function right
and that's what that cute little diagram
was remember in the documentation for
net trainers explaining how we do that
and so we give a whole there's a rich
language that you can use to to do
specific things when you create this
training Network from the original
network but there's no way
straightforward way to like see what
their training network is it's just
something that net rain does and it's
like I understand to create what do you
mean creating the training Network so
we've got an original network and then
what's the difference between the
training network and the and it's a
network with a bunch of weights and the
training function is going to adjust the
weights the training network
often turns the output of the Audrey
Network into an input okay so I'm not
sure we've really gone through this so
what is this now look at the middle
picture okay so that sub piece there the
cyan net that's the training that's the
ordinary network that's the what you
gave to net train the other bigger
network by connecting the purple loss
layer to the network typically wait wait
what where's the where's the lost layer
coming from it's chosen based on the
network automatically so for example the
issue is if you want to give a different
loss layer to net train how do you do
that I mean you can really there's a
grammar for how you do this if you look
up and says when a loss there's chosen
automatically for report the loss there
to users based on the layer within the
net output is connected to the port as
follows blah blah blah okay but what
happens if you want to specify your own
loss layer or loss function which could
in general be an arbitrary loss function
it doesn't have to be a single layer
isn't that true yes you can't do that
and there's nothing stopping you from
doing all of these things now the
difficulty is that you don't ever get to
see the final training network that is
constructed based on your specification
so I'm suggesting splitting off that
functionality into a function separate
function that takes the same it's the
same argument that net train takes but
it just shows you what the training
network is and if you want to you can
then do that as a separate step and I
think it's useful for for pedagogical
reasons to like see to break off this
the step to show you what the magic is
so maybe that should be an option to net
train what if ik property of the
training session
why not just say right because net train
you're saying that's pre processing the
net train is doing on the network to
prepare it to be trained correct right
so let's look at what those properties
can be let's see where do we have that
specified property can be any of the
following
yeah the trained Network that's the
output from this well why don't we say
why don't we have a setting for you no
value for property that gives you the to
be trained Network
yeah okay that's one way to do it sure
we could do that seems sensible right
because that way we don't I mean I don't
see the reason to introduce a whole
nother because this is part of the
functionality of net train it's just
short-circuiting it and not going
through the whole was not actually
training anything so it's it is
violating the one the verb in the name
of the function it's no longer doing any
train well it is it is providing the
training Network although it is not I
mean we could potentially say training
net that is the network which will be
trained so I've already I've done it
this way already I'm trying to remember
what the property I gave it is but
clearly I hadn't documented it yet so
let me I'm suggesting training Network
perhaps represent the network to be
trained I call it a loss net but we
could call it a training network well if
it's the whole network it should not be
called a loss net yeah that's better
what do you think for in terms of name I
prefer training this I agree with
Stephen leicht loss net is a bit strange
okay cool you want to add it yeah I'll
add it up future eyes it or are you is
it there's actually a lot of properties
that we added in the cycle that have
just been collecting up which we should
review and reminders we'll review it in
this meeting so let me I'll put them in
an email while we talk about something
else okay all right okay the network
to be trained
you
let's see the network
the network prepared for training I like
that and then you could answer that by
attaching I don't know well lost layers
how about that yes we could do that okay
as prepared for training by appending
lost layers yes yeah I mean sometimes we
don't do that it depends on the actual
network but in general that's what
happens yeah let's make it as a separate
note um n remember we have a whole
section of the notes that tells you how
we constructed it's right above you so
we might want to mention it there okay
yeah we just say like the property
training net can be used to retrieve
this network this network
read it through later okay let's come
back to this when we go back to talk
about other properties let's let's right
now that's still within that state or
object okay um so this is slightly
tricky right because this is supposed to
represent a mutable okay
net state object so let's take a look at
how we would say this um represents an
updatable
you
which represents a neuron that with
updatable state derived from net is that
correct yes hmm looks like we have a
spelling word though do you think it's
spelled correctly there or do you think
it's update a bow like that
um maybe Sushma could ask gqa and they
could tell us and we could add this to
the spelling dictionary when or when we
know what the right answer is okay um
let's take a look at this net to take
net chain as an example
that a reasonable description here
I mean there's some points that I'd want
to fit into that sentence somehow like
for example the state is stored inside
the object know if that's obvious from
the wedding that you have with a stored
updatable state initially initiate
represents initially and you're on that
initially of the initially derived from
net can you say represents a version of
net in which there is a storm state AB
stored updatable state no because that's
not the right thing because this is oh
well wait a minute which part of net
ends up being updated here that is if
we've got a net a random network so tell
me the answer to that question I've got
just a random network with you know
random linear layers and things like
this what if I feed that into a net
state object what can I apply to the net
state object and then I just start you
know so what happens is when we have net
state object of net applied to data
right that is going to actually cause an
update to occur is that correct yes
that's correct but you see I was in it
in the thing you just wrote in it yes
creates a neuron that um it's a neuron
that's derived from net but with a
stored updatable state but more correct
it's this one little niggle there which
is that it's the thing it creates is not
really an it in that doesn't work with
all the ordinary functions like net
extract or whatever you can take out the
net from inside it better
just like for now it's an opaque object
doesn't behave like a net except for
evaluation we okay visit that but okay
how do you get the net out from inside
it you could just say create some
objects a good question I propose normal
okay that will get the current state of
the net out that correct no because yes
well yes and as it stands now there's no
recurrent states aren't even stored in a
net in the first place so what you get
out towards me what you put in and all
the recurrent states just evaporate
there's nowhere to put them in the net
they've completely ephemeral so future
if they're different kinds of audio as
science returns to us wait audio is
beginning to break up to keep going
sorry well yeah okay so what hello can
you hear me okay no yep so you're saying
that it's net net state object is
storing additional information
but within it with additional stored
updatable state information
yes okay creates an object derived from
the neural net derived from net that
represents a neural net with additional
stored updatable state information
that right yes um
one potential clarification is that the
user can't directly update anything so
updatable suggests that the user can I
see I see I see I see
I mean if with additional state
information that is updated that is
updated when the net is evaluated when
the yeah when the net is evaluated is
that right when the object is yes when
the object is applied when the net is
applied to data yeah perfect let's put
applied to input
to input and in mind okay all right
so then what we have to say is um so
let's see the see also is here will be
to net chain and net graph correct yeah
and crucially oh I think it should be a
list of all the layers that right you'll
actually do this the various recurrent
layers right yeah okay so let's look
here and I should need to remind myself
what those actually are um so let's see
where are they recurrent layers there
those three layers right basic recurrent
gated recurrent and lsdm yes there's
there's also knit fold operator okay
that was brilliant
not very useful um okay I think it's
faster just to type it net recurrent
basically current layer um
our gated recurrent layer long
short-term memory
they are very boring to watch being
typed okay NAT fold operator right
yes okay someone is asking from our
livestream does net state object just
two forward and backward pass with
preserving our an end state is that
right it's it represents and it
represents recurrent states at the
moment I mean other kinds of states that
we want to talk good to us represent
I'll use your example wasted condition
tally your audio at home disconnection
tree thanks
Sebastian well we're at it let's sum
okay
you know finish with that question or I
can tell you well did you know the
answer to the end of that question Sean
so right now it's the only state is as
represented as the recurrent states in
the future we want to represent states
like doing background for buses and it
has and you can update those objects you
can do get the gradient and then have
your own little gradient update rule and
then update this object something how
would you update the object that's a
good question we haven't thought about
this that much yes the next few days is
this prototype what it would look like
and we can show this to you of course if
it's if it is deeply incompatible with
this basic plan of this net state object
we have now then we will pull an
in-state object for this version but I
really don't anticipate that that's
gonna happen well let's talk about it
for a minute how would you do a by hand
ok so what's happening here is there is
an implicit update which comes by just
running the data through the net state
object right yep okay so now there is
the question of an explicit effectively
net train operation being done on the
net state object is that correct that's
correct
well not quite so the the way the thing
you often wants to do whether it's my
audio better perfect but go ahead okay I
don't know if like maybe Mac is doing a
download in the background or something
but it's doing so often you want to
train a single thing two different ways
simultaneously right that's what makes
it impossible to express with a niche
trade and in such a situation you don't
want to take one state object and then
make two different training objects
quite unquote from it okay on it and
then update those those training objects
feed them data as you desire okay that's
like one way of framing this whole thing
so it's not necessarily that you call
all net train with the state object it's
more that you create training objects
multiple ones and then you can you can
step them through an update process
individually independent of the original
let's do the whole thing so if we take
nap train net train is a kind of just a
big automated thing that does the
training what you're saying is net train
contains sub pieces that you may need to
break out yes so what are those sub
pieces we think that it'll be creating a
training object okay from a state object
so there'll be something maybe they
create training object let me okay
let me try to solve that'll be maybe
Sebastian okay it's just a person okay
cool so just just for context for this
thing so there's two sort of places
where a formalism like net trained as a
minion so where for Mirza magnet train
doesn't breaks down and the two major
cases are for reinforcement learning and
the other one is for Ganz mmm-hmm what
those workflows are okay first
reinforcement learning
okay so reinforcement learning what you
do is the question is you how do you get
a gradient estimate of sum of anything
so you have a network that basically
proposes a step so it gets some
information like for example an Atari
game it'll look at the screen and we'll
say you've got five controls here's a
probability distribution across those
five controls mmm so that's what the
policy network can do for for this so
the question is how do you train the
policy network so the answer for that is
that you basically you take a policy
network and you use sample actions from
it so it makes a prediction of what what
to do then you run you know you use that
action you feed that action into the
environment the environment feeds you
back another state the network sees that
state again
the same process happens again and again
right so how does that relate to the
workflow that we already have for things
like active classify it's weird I mean
I've got find that it shouldn't happen
okay so how does it relate how does what
you're describing in that workflow
relate to how active classification
works
so okay myself of this so this is this
is a thing where you're trying to learn
a classifier and you make you have to
make a choice at each step what example
you are generating your own examples by
applying a function that potentially
does something in the real world yes
okay so walk me through how this is so
what we're describing could be used to
implement a deep learning backend for
active classification for example okay
so uh what are we describing is a fairly
low level it's like the building blocks
that you could build many different you
could use reduce reinforcement learning
you could do it for Ganz all right let
me walk through again what you're
actually saying so you say instead of a
net train where you know generally net
train takes the net a single net and you
know a collection of examples mm-hmm
right yeah okay so what are you now
saying so basically instead of that you
have a net and you have an environment
objects yeah it's like the Atari game
and there's always known as a function
that will generate them in here we've
got particular configurations right an
otherwise active classification here
takes this function f right using the
function f to define classes for example
configurations so that's the environment
specification there is that function f
okay I'm not mistaken
I'll check the spit it's plausible
there two things we could talk about we
could talk about how to do reinforcement
blow me right deep how to do deep
reinforcement learning as a custom
function or we could just talk about how
state objects can be used in all these
different ways including deep
reinforcement learning well I'm more i I
just want to check that that the
reinforcement learning path is actually
going to work that's that was the only
reason I'm bringing this up because I
mean we're defining the state object
thing and what you're saying is I
understand how the state object thing is
useful once we have things like a
language model where the actual network
is going to change as it's fed data
again that now you're claiming that this
generalizes to a different case where
the way you need to you know nip and
tuck the network well basically you're
writing your own training loop I
understand so what's in a training loop
there's usually an outer loop and then
depending on the the kind of task that
you're doing you might have one or more
networks that interact in various ways
to generate gradients that are then used
to update the weights of those networks
right so one of the things we don't have
so how do we derive the gradients from a
network
don't we have we were going to have we
don't have it yet its net derivative so
right yeah or is it net gradient we have
net net port gradient convey a port
gradient is it's not enough it's not a
function like that it's it's more of a
property description that you can use
with existing networks to ask to get
concrete gradients what specific inputs
but tell me the grade into this input so
you say like net open bracket input
comma net port gradient input ok zin
yeah what event code what are you saying
well that's no no quotes it's that's the
data itself input as a variable
we've data okay okay okay
and then instead of asking for an output
the second argument you know is the
property that you want yeah I understand
that gradient of some random port yeah
well multiple of course right okay fine
so that's the way of querying for a
gradient but my question is given a
particular network and particular data
what we need is the analog of you know
what would qualitatively to be
derivative of net that's data right
derivative actually what this really is
is you know it's actually kind of an
interesting thing because right if you
actually look at if I say F prime you
know D of f of X Y comma X comma 2 for
example right I'll get that what is that
that is the derivative of the second
derivative with respect to us
yeah it's the the second derivative in
the first slot of this function f on x
and y so what we want presumably is the
analog of that for a network where we're
saying the you know net derivative if
I'm not mistaken of essentially with
respect to such and such a port if I'm
not for training for training you don't
really want that this is not really this
this feature it's not very useful for
training because what you really want
there's the derivative on the weights
the gradient on the weights right yes
derivative of the loss with respect to
the weights so and then you want to take
that and then you want to use it to
update the weights in a complicated way
based on a certain optimization
algorithm so most people don't want to
write their and optimize this they don't
want to do plus equals blah blah blah
blah blah with the grade in strictly
they just want to say use an
off-the-shelf optimizer like Adam to
update this following net based on
gradients that I've generated in some
way our our live stream commentator here
is saying basically new control from
which network from which network node to
back propagate similar to tensor flow
with several losses and optimizes that
run separately
yes yes that's what that's what the two
trainer thing that I was referring to
earlier is okay well do we understand
what this is going to look like roughly
what do we mean roughly but we haven't
what we haven't done is prototype it and
until we've prototype it's very easy to
be have like a mental model it's not
it's not actually so my question for net
state object is there is one use case
for net state object at this time you
imagine that net state object yes
like the weights for examples if you're
doing this this custom training loop you
definitely want you know you want the
weights to be a states of the this
object and then updates
how are you specifying that this
information is that how you specifying
which information is updated because
normally when you apply a net to data it
just applies itself to the data how does
this know that inside one of these
recurrent layers that there is something
that is going to be updated as opposed
to just do it and you know move on so
state ports are special so they the ones
that's the input and the output port and
in the same so we already have this net
state port is that correct
what we have now it's net it's a new
usage of net port remember it's you can
pass them in and get them out by saying
all common states that's what we
designed like two three weeks ago okay
so we need that here yes we know just
this this this relates to net ports that
are specified how also what do we say we
are going to run out of time here so
the one random thing by the way can you
can you give some some guidance to for
me to send to Jeremy about the icon for
net state object just because I need to
get yeah yeah right well I mean that
thing is ridiculous I know it's not did
you actually get that from a recycle bin
it's a unique icon for recycling okay
great yeah okay we can it can and there
you have to read off that the
regulations for the particular town
you're in about where you recycle um
there okay well what really is this this
is a network and by the way if we're
gonna discuss this why don't we get
Billy to join us because he's probably
gonna be the one I'm actually making
icon icon okay
so this needs to go with
let's see um well what are we really
trying to represent here this is
something where the state that's fed in
sticks inside the object
Oh
what do you guys think I mean guess how
I did I would have a little box and it's
got an arrow passing through it
horizontally that represents the input
in the output and then it's on another
error passing through it vertically
which represents and kind of loops back
don't I mean not really but um okay um
so you're proposing well let's let's see
if um let's see let me use my really
high-tech
you
okay all right so you're saying what are
you suggesting you're suggesting a
horizontal arrow like that going through
this is really weird going through
something that looks like a chain and
then some recycling arrow like that that
seems kind of goofy to me well I
wouldn't do a chain just do a square so
okay got it we heard it on the left I'll
put on the right okay and that's that's
walnut
okay wraps at that yes that's an it
what's different about this guy is that
it's got a loop coming from the bottom
back up to the top or something like
that how does it loop around for I don't
know what are you trying to represent
here trying to represent the fact that
it has internal state that yeah but now
this this notion with arrows is what
we've used to represent individual
layers isn't that right
not yet sleep networks
I don't know I I don't really believe in
something like this that just seems
completely goofy um
but okay let's um let's continue with
the rest of the discussion for a minute
I mean in worst case you know since this
is identified as a net state object we
don't absolutely need an icon there um
right okay but I still want to
understand what it is we're saying here
so the first thing to say is a net state
object of net
generates well let's see um
that creates an object and then the the
other thing that we need here is
something which has a dot dot dot if I'm
not mistaken
that is what does this look like after
you create the net state object right
here what does that thing look like
internally yeah it's the net and then
it's an association of the states okay
but do we need to document that
separately because this is both a
generator I don't I mean zero is a
perfectly good initial State
but there was somebody
asking on the livestream have a document
ie additional information on top of the
neck yes we are very much on top of that
we have this whole elaborate neural net
repository that has huge amounts of
additional information associated with
networks so for example this is a
typical
network with examples and it has all
kinds of it has its construction
notebook that shows how the network has
put together etc etcetera etcetera so I
think we're in good shape in terms of
that um that aspect of things um let's
go back um ok sorry what were you saying
here
you're
so hold on net so the you're describing
what happens
okay so this
is there a separate line we have to give
it creates an object arrived from the
network
you
you
let's see so
I'm trying to understand how this
creates an object which is in fact also
a net state object am i making sense
you guys there
nor Talia's disappeared sorry you guys
cut out for a second what was it I was
saying this is a creator and a
representa of the net state object right
yes it is
so I think we need another usage line
here that says something like represents
you
let's see represents a neural net with
additional stored state information I
mean is that it's a little bit confusing
well we do we don't do this elsewhere
like net information do you know that
information doesn't generate something
it does not bother generally trying to
represent her it does look good
[Music]
I'm sorry not not dead information
classified information the information
doesn't do this yet
but we were going to make do
you
what do you mean who does this
that generates a report giving
information on customer function I
suppose we don't say what that report is
no okay I'm not certain we should do it
hit this here so let's feature eyes that
for a second but let's try and write the
rest of it here okay
net state object okay
not state object of data updates stored
state information
in the net state object
you
um stored state information
information
you
what are we going to say can be stored
in recurrent net layers such as basic
recurrent layer is that correct yes and
now what how do we say this in in
weights
I always say this how do we describe the
net that consists in you should say
state of the information is associated
with recurrent net layers such as
basement later ok I'm gonna have to go
in a moment here so I think you guys
need to continue this yeah but in
particular by the way there's a second
usage that we need to I'll tell you the
use case sequence to sequence type
models where it's like it eats English
and spits out French there's a the way
you do it is that first it eats the
English and it produces a state and then
you use that as an seed and then you
generate to produce the French ok so
what's the use case I mean what's the
description here it's something like a
second argument which you use to create
those initial States and it's basically
an association that's the same form as
net ports all comma States returns so ok
so that's not just net that's something
where that that's a place where what
you're giving if I'm if I'm not mistaken
is a net state object
you
of Netcom estate info I noticed you said
you need to go but Chris priorities here
with us as well okay um and it's
basically the seed and that seed is zero
like if you don't provide that state
then this is the right right
creates an object
let's see in which
additional stored state information is
initialized using state they're correct
if we could call it seed
okay this is a Chris we are trying to
have you been following the neural net
iconography stuff or are you not have
you not been involved in this following
that a little bit and I've been working
on something somewhat related for
another task okay fine all right we need
another icon which represents one of
these net state objects which is her
neuron that in which as you apply it to
data like a brain so to speak it kind of
learns by doing if you understand what
I'm saying mm-hmm
so in other words rather than being
explicitly trained in a separate now
you're going to school type thing it is
you know it is learning on the job
so to speak um so we need an icon for
that okay
the current icon it's ridiculous it's
this recycling bin thing yeah the brain
we just of the abstract I think yes we
do not want a brain um so we're looking
for an icon that is communicating
adapting it's a it's communicating that
it is anything
well it's changing on the fly so it
could be for learning purposes or it
could just be that just remembering what
it's done already and it's doing
something different okay yeah how do you
represent something arrow going to box
and then coming out again does the
ordinary I'm now doing my artwork here
so so what are you saying you're saying
an arrow just what you had a bit of
right with it instead of a recycle no
and then draw faint ghost boxes behind
that first box that are kind of offset
diagonally yes and that represents
previous versions of the box I say okay
so we're it's it's sort of a pseudo 3d
thing where we sort of a z-axis that's
going back in time but also this is why
to show input and output that's causing
the change no well maybe one could have
ghosted our
is going in there the ghosted arrows and
then this is a solid arrow here yeah
yeah machine visualizes things you know
going back in time the Apple thing um
okay that seems reasonable to me now
what about the iconography of the of the
box to represent the complete network
I thought we would have
I would think it would be better to have
something that looks more networking
because I think those pure boxes are
what we be used for individual layers if
that's not if I'm not mistaken mm-hmm
but you can always have something that
looks Network II inside here yeah so
we'd have the box and pretty as realist
rating there wouldn't we wouldn't arrows
coming in and out because we are
indicating that it is a fully developed
Network yes but these arrows here well I
see what you're saying
hmm well to win it you're saying why do
we have the arrows coming in and out
because we don't have arrows coming in
and out on this one for the completed
networks do we want the arrows coming in
and out no I don't think so yeah I would
I would think that either Kyle I see so
just the just the roof of the stack of
things well the one thing and maybe it's
two maybe it's two devoted to this
current use case but the reason it's
changing is that you're feeding it new
data right but maybe yeah we might not
for you which it might not be it might
be changing because something else
changed in what I'm describing with the
training objects so that seems
reasonable to like drop the arrows right
but on the other hand that is suggesting
that the thing that's here is a history
and it's not it is merely the current
state
but I suppose that if what you're
representing if you're ghosting back the
historical stuff then that might be a
here's how we got here
you go what I'm saying Chris I mean this
actual thing is just representing where
you're at
yeah I would have to do is employing
with it but I initially liked the idea
of keeping the ghosted out layers in the
background because it shows that this
has been trained and data has gone into
it to Train it fair enough all right why
don't you try it see what you can come
up with what's that I was gonna take a
quick screenshot of your icon right
there but I think I got go ahead good
it's not hardly a brilliant piece of
artwork okay okay I think we have to
wrap right now
and we'll continue I guess in the next
few days and I will push this back into
the repository thanks to those who
happen to be on the livestream we will
actually be back with a completely
different subject in about an hour and a
half talking about financial data feeds
so see you later bye